A
comedy-genius, Moranis quietly vanished from
acting in 1997, when he was last seen on screen
in the movie titled ‘Big Bully.’
He had been slowly disappearing from the public
eye after his wife’s death from breast cancer
that had spread to her liver in 1991.
Why the disappearing act?
He chose to leave Hollywood to be a stay-at-home
dad and raise his children.
A few months ago (July of 2013), he opened
up about his unpopular choice to walk away
from fame at the peak of his career during
a rare interview on Bullseye with Jesse Thorn.
(Definitely worth a full listen if you’re
a fan of Moranis.)
The actor says he simply wanted to recreate
the same wonderful childhood for his kids
that he experienced.
In his own words:
Well, stuff happens to people everyday and
they make adjustments in their lives for all
kinds of reasons, and there was nothing unusual
about what happened or what I did.
I think the reason people were intrigued about
the decisions I was making, and sometimes
seem to have almost admiration for it, had
less to do with the fact that I was doing
what I was doing and more to do with what
they thought I was walking away from- as if
what I was walking away from had far greater
value than anything else might.
The decision in my case to become a stay at
home dad, which people do all the time, I
guess wouldn’t have meant much to people
if I had had a very simple kind of “make-a-living”
existence and decided, “You know what?
I need to spend more time at home.
I’m not going to do that.
I’m going to do this part time and then
work out of my house to do this and this and
this.”
But because I came from celebrity and fame
and what was a peak of a career, that was
intriguing to people and to me it wasn’t
that.
It wasn’t anything to do with that.
It was just work and it was time to make an
adjustment…
I was trying to recreate a lot of the joy
I experienced as a kid…
[I] kind of decided to follow the adage of
“90% of the success is showing up or being
there” and I found that to be true.
Just being there was the best thing I could
do.
That’s what I experienced with my mother
at home all the time and so when my kids came
home there was music and there were lights
on there were great smells coming out of the
kitchen and it was just always a joyous place
to be and that’s what I wanted, what I wanted
to create.
I didn’t walk away from [my creativity],
I applied all my creativity to my home life,
to me kids, to my family.
I was the same person, I didn’t change,
I just shifted my focus.
So does he miss acting?
I missed the people, and I missed the very
refreshing nature of doing something radically
different every day.
Raising kids and being a stay at home parent,
especially being a single stay at home parent,
is a lot of sameness.
It’s a very different kind of life than
being on a set with Aykroyd and Murray and
Steve Martin…
Will Moranis make a return to the limelight?
After all, his kids are grown now.
I’m not interested in doing anything I’ve
done in the past.
In terms of being on camera, I have no idea.
It’s not something I’ve given any thought
to at all…
I have never had a plan, I’ve never had
any forethought of anything I’ve ever done.
I just kind of looked at opportunities, said
no to most things and sometimes whatever was
left standing was the thing that I went for
and sometimes something came along that was
so appealing I just jumped
at it…
In the end, Moranis summed up his disappearance
from acting quite well:
I’m a single parent and I just found that
it was too difficult to manage raising my
kids and doing the travelling involved in
making movies.
So I took a little bit of a break.
And the little bit of a break turned into
a longer break, and then I found that I really
didn’t miss it.